Transcriber: hassnaa mouden
المدقّق: Ayman Mahmoud
قبل فترة لعبت مع زملائي لعبة تعارف،
مثل ما هو لونك المفضل؟
ما هي اكثر اكلة تحبها؟
وسئلت هذا السؤال:
“?what is your superpower”
ومعناه بالعربية ما هي قوتك الخارقة؟
سوبر باور هي القوة الخارقة.
وأنا سرحت بهذا السؤال لأنه عميق بعض الشيء.
فقلت أنا ليس لدي قوة خارقة
فأنا من العراق، ولدت في عائلة بسيطة،
في منطقة شعبية بمدينة الحرية
تحية خاصة لمدينة الحرية
(تصفيق)
و في الواقع لم يكن لدينا بيت،
لأني ولدت بغرفة
عائلتي كانت تعيش في غرفة واحدة ببيت جدي.
وكنت أحس بنوع من الإحراج
وأنني أقل شأنا من الآخرين بسبب هذا الأمر.
لدرجة أنني لم أكن أخبر أصدقائي
بالمدرسة أين أعيش
وأننا نعيش بغرفة واحدة
ولا أملك غرفة نومي الشخصية
أبي كان يشتغل بوظيفتين
وظيفة بالنهار و وظيفة بالليل
حتى يوفر نقودا ليكون بها نفسه
ويشتري لنا بيتا نفتخر به
وبعد سنين من التعب،
وأخيرا صار لدينا بيت من طابقين،
وأصبحت لدي غرفة نوم منفردة،
هذه نافذة غرفتي وبها شرفة خاصة.
لكن للأسف لم نفرح بهذا البيت،
بعد فترة قصيرة قتل والدي وأخي الكبير
بانفجار سيارة مفخخة
لذلك هجرنا بيتنا الجديد،
وأصبحنا ننتقل من بيت لبيت،
قضينا فترة ببيت جدي، وفترة ببيت آخر،
فأنا
فجأة عائلتي
وكأن حياتنا انتهت وأنا بعمر الثانية
أو الثالث عشرة سنة .
وكنت في ذلك الوقت
لا أريد الإنتحار ولا أفكر فيه،
لكن كنت أستمتع بفكرة أنه قد يأتي يوم ما
وأموت بانفجار سيارة مفخخة مثل أبي وأخي
فعن أي سوبر باور تتحدثون؟
أنا عشت حياة مليئة بالمصائب والكوارث.
وأكبر إنجاز في حياتي
أني لا زلت على قيد الحياة،
بعد هذه الانفجارات و الحروب الطائفية .
وحين كنت طالبا بمدرسة الموهوبين،
كنت أذهب بالقوة إلى المدرسة،
وكنت شخصا مجتهدا،
كانت درجاتي جيدة،
وأحيانا أكون الأول في صفي،
لدرجة أنني تخرجت من الإعدادية
بعمر الخامس عشرة سنة بسبب اجتهادي
كان كل شيء رائعا،
وحصلت على منحة بجامعة كندية،
وسأذهب للدراسة خارج البلاد،
يا إلهي كم هذا رائع!
لكن المشكلة أنه لكي أستطيع السفر والدراسة،
أحتاج إلى جواز سفر،
وكانت عائلتنا تعاني ماديا ذلك الوقت،
لدرجة أننا لا نستطيع تحمل
تكاليف جواز السفر
ولا أعلم إن كنتم تتذكرون ذلك الوقت،
كان قد صدر جواز جديد،
الجواز الكتروني
يدفع الناس مبالغ كبيرة للحصول عليه،
ونحن لا نملك هذا المبلغ،
بعدها تطوع ناس لمساعدتي
واستطعت الحصول عليه،
لكن تبين لي بعد ذلك أن جواز السفر
الذي أحتاجه للسفر به،
سيعرقل سفري،
لأن جواز السفر العراقي،
هو أسوء جواز سفر بالعالم،
وإذا أردت الذهاب والدراسة في كندا،
حصلت على هذه المنحة،
وأنا أعيش في العراق،
وحتى أذهب الى كندا لو كنت إنسانا عاديا.
كنت سأستقل الطائرة،
وأسافر من بغداد بالعراق لأصل إلى كندا
لكنني لست شخصا عاديا
أنا عراقي،
(يضحك)
(تصفيق)
قلت سابقا أنني أحتاج إلى تأشيرة
للذهاب إلى كندا
ولم تكن التأشيرة متوفرة في العراق آنذاك
لم تكن هناك سفارة كندية بالعراق
فحتى أحصل على هذه التأشيرة،
علي الذهاب إلى السفارة الكندية بالأردن،
والمفاجأة أنه لكي أذهب إلى الأردن،
يجب أن أحصل هنا على تاشيرة،
وتأشيرة الأردن ليست متوفرة هنا في العراق
فاضطررت إلى فعل شيء جنوني حينها،
بعثت جوازي من بغداد إلى السفارة الاردنية
بواشنطن في أمريكا
حتى أحصل على تأشيرة للأردن،
بعثوا لي جواز سفري بالبريد،
وبعدها ذهبت إلى الأردن،
تقدمت بطلب للحصول على تأشيرة كندا،
وانتظرت شهرين تقريبا،
وبعدها سافرت من الأردن الى كندا،
مررت من كل هذا
لأنني أحمل جواز السفر العراقي
هذا الجواز العراقي،
واجهت كل هذه المشاكل والصعوبات
لأنني أحمل هذا الجواز،
وفي الحقيقه أنا لا أحمل جواز سفر بل لعنة
لعنة رافقتني منذ أن كنت أعيش بالعراق،
هذه المعاناة والمصاعب التي عشتها،
كانت معي عندما أردت الخروج من العراق،
وظلت معي حتى بعدما هاجرت من العراق،
بحيث كلما ذهبت إلى مطار أو سفارة
للحصول على تأشيرة جديدة
أتعرض لأبشع أنواع الذل والمهانة
و يعاملونني بدونية.
وفي إحدى المرات،
سجنت في أحد المطارات بإفريقيا،
وأنا مسجون،
قررت أن أصور نفسي وأنا بالسجن لشدة الملل،
[تنزانيا]
فصورت نفسي وأنا أدق باب السجن.
(تصفيق)
سجنت لمدة يوم كامل
لأنني أحمل جواز سفر عراقي
عن أي سوبر باور تتحدثون؟
أنا أعيش حياتي بصعوبة.
أعتقد أن هذا يكفي لقد وصلت الفكرة،
حياة العراقي صعبة.
وبعد مرور السنوات تخرجت من الجامعة،
وبدأت أشتغل بشركة الفيسبوك،
بمقرها الرئيسي بكاليفورنيا،
وفي يوم من الأيام كان لدينا تقييم،
كل ستة أشهر يتم تقييمنا من طرف المدير،
يسألني ماذا فعلت خلال هذه المدة
وكيف كان أدائي،
وأخبرني أنا هنا لأبشرك،
لقد كان أداءك رائعا،
وسأعطيك اليوم ترقية،
وقد كتب تقريرا
من ثلاث صفحات تقريبا يشرح فيه
كل الإنجازات التي حققتها خلال هذا العمل
حتى يبرر سبب ترقيتي، وكتب فيه هذه العبارة:
you demonstrated extreme ]
[grit to grind through all the issues
ما معنى هذه العبارة؟
ترجمتها..
(يضحك)
سأترجمها لكم بالعربية بصوت مديري
لقد أبديت إصرارا وعزما شديدا
كي تتغلب على المصاعب.
طبعا هو لايتكلم العربية لأنه فنلندي
ترجمت الجملة بواسطة غوغل.
عن ماذا يتحدث هذا الرجل ؟
هل ستتم ترقيتي حقا؟
عن ماذا يتحدث ؟
من أين أتيت بهذا الإصرار والعزيمة الشديدة؟
سرحت بأفكاري،
وسألت نفسي كيف اكتسبت هذه المهارات؟
وعندما حاولت تذكر بداياتي
أتذكر هذه الصورة،
(ضحك)
(تصفيق)
أنا لا أعرف أعماركم
ولا أعلم إن كنتم عاصرتم هذا الإختراع
مولد التايجر
كنا نستعمله بسنتي 2004 و 2005،
كنا لا نستغني عنه لتوليد الكهرباء،
قبل أن تتطور وتتحسن وضعية العراق،
كنا نستعمل هذه المولدات دائما
وإذا تعطلت نعيش بالظلام،
وأنا كنت أحيانا
إذا تعطلت ولا نستطيع تحمل تكاليف إصلاحه
أحاول تفكيكه
وفصل أجزائه،
وأظل أحاول مرة تلو الأخرى حتى أصلحه
فيشتغل المولد ونعيد استعماله،
وقد كنت بعمر 12 أو 13 سنة،
ولم تكن يوتيوب موجودة آنذاك،
ولا حتى غوغل أو إنترنت.
وحين أفكر بالإصرار و العزيمة،
أتذكر هذه القنينة التي سعتها 20 لترا،
كنت أذهب إلى محطة الوقود،
وأظل لمدة خمس إلى عشرة ساعات بوقت الأزمة،
أحيانا يأتي شخص عنيف و يحاول مهاجمتي بسكين
يدفعني فأعود للبيت وأعود في اليوم الموالي،
وللمرة الثانية حاملا قنينات جديدة،
و أذهب لمحطة الوقود،
لأننا لا نستطيع تدفئة البيت
إذا لم يكن لدينا بنزين،
أو التوفر على كهرباء.
وهذه اللحظات كانت أول ما تذكرته،
فقد تحليت فيها بالإصرار والعزيمة،
وهذا ما قصده مديري
وهما أيضا ما احتجته للحصول
على تأشيرة كندا،
وأستفيد من المنحة التي حصلت عليها
فمن خلال هذه الذكريات تغيرت نظرتي للأمور،
تغيرت نظرتي لهويتي العراقية،
اكتشفت أني كنت أكره كوني عراقيا،
وكان لدي غضب عارم اتجاه هذا الموضوع
لكن تبين لي أن هذه الأمور الصعبة،
هي التي أعطتني سوبر باور،
فأصبحت أقول أن سوبر باور
التي أملكها هي كوني عراقيا.
(هتاف الجمهور)
(تصفيق)
[ My super power is that I’m Iraqi ]
سوبر باور التي أملكها هي كوني عراقيا.
ليس لأن أباءنا وأجدادنا هم السماريون،
وأول من اخترع الكتابة،
ما علاقتي بكل هذا؟
ما أحاول قوله أن التحديات التي واجهتها،
جعلتني أكتسب الشجاعة والإصرار
للنجاح في حياتي،
واليوم اتخذ مديري قرارا بترقيتي،
بسبب هذه الأمور التي تعلمتها في العراق،
وهذا ليس رأيي فقط،
بل هناك العديد من المؤثرين،
وعدة أبحاث تؤكد هذا الكلام.
يقولون أن الصعاب التي واجهوها في بداياتهم
كانت عاملا مهما لنجاحهم،
هذه السيدة تشتغل مديرة الموارد البشرية
بالشركة العالمية يو بي اس
حيث تحدثت عن الموضوع في TED قائلة
أنها تنصح العاملين بالموارد البشرية
الذين يعينون موظفين جدد،
ألا يعطوا الأولوية لصاحب الإنجازات العظيمة
لأن حياته كانت مثالية،
وإنما للذين واجهوا تحديات في حياتهم
حتى لو كانت إنجازاتهم متواضعة .
لأن هذه التحديات والصعوبات وإصرارهم
ترفع من احتمالات نجاحهم،
وتجعلهم أكثر نجاحا
من صاحب الإنجازات والحياة المثالية.
وأنا الآن أشعر بأني قادر على فعل أي شيء،
لأني عراقي.
باستثناء الزواج لأنه موضوع صعب
و لست مستعدا بعد.
لكن من بين الأشياء
التي أحاول القيام بها حاليا،
هو زيارة كل دول العالم بواسطة جواز سفري,
الذي تسبب لي في عقدة،
وقد أخذت هذا الموضوع كتحدي
وأؤمن بقدرتي على تحقيقه
رغم أني كنت أراه مستحيلا.
فكيف سأزور كل هذه الدول
وأنا أجد صعوبة في الحصول على تأشيرة؟
وأنا الذي أريد زيارة كل دول العالم تقريبا.
لكن وبسبب إصراري وعزيمتي
زرت لحد الآن 120 دولة.
بجواز السفر العراقي.
(تصفيق)
ويسألني الناس دائما كيف استطعت ذلك.
الموضوع بسيط .
بسبب الإصرار والعزيمة،
الخصال التي نمتلكها جميعا
أذهب إلى السفارات
وأتقدم بطلب تأشيرة عدة مرات .
أتقدم بطلب تأشيرة في سفارة أخرى.
أو أجدد جواز سفري.
أحاول الحصول على دعوة لمؤتمر
أو أتقدم بطلب في دولة أخرى
أحاول مرة تلو الأخرى من أجل تاشيرة واحدة.
حتى أني استغليت فتاة لأحصل على تأشيرة،
أنا أمزح فحسب.
(تصفيق)
قبل يومين كنت بدولة جزر القمر.
وكنت أحضر نفسي لخطاب اليوم.
واليوم عدة أشخاص ظنوني أجنبيا
وسألونى عن جنسيتي،
فأجبتهم أني من جزر القمر
وظنوا أني أمازحهم،
مع أنني أتيت من هناك فعلا.
سأحدثكم قليلا عن الأماكن التي زرتها
ذهبت لأقصى نقطة في شمال أوروبا
لرؤية الشمس هناك
فهي لا تغرب لمدة شهرين ونصف.
التقطت هذه الصورة في منتصف الليل،
كانت الشمس مشرقة لمدة شهرين.
من المفترض أن تقولوا هذا رائع!
(ضحك الجمهور)
وذهبت إلى بوليفيا أيضا
لزيارة المسطح المعروف بأكبر مرآة بالعالم،
(يضحك)
(تصفيق)
هذا جزء من إنجازاتي.
لكن بالنسبة لي السفر ليس فقط
فرصة لالتقاط صور خرافية وزيارة أماكن جميلة
بل هو مدرسة و حتى كلمة مدرسة لا توفيه حقه
إذ يجب أن يكون جزءا من التعليم الإلزامي
لما فيه من فائدة للشعوب
ومن أكثر المواقف التي تأثرت بها
حضوري لذكرى إحياء الإبادة
التي حدثت في رواندا
وهي دولة إفريقية شهدت قبل 25 سنة تقريبا
مجزرة قتل فيها خلال مائة يوم مليون شخص.
كارثة! تخيل دولة بها سبعة مليون شخص
وقارنها بالعراق كنسبة أي ما يقارب
6 مليون شخص يموتون خلال مائة يوم .
هذه فاجعة ومصيبة كبيرة
لكن أراها من أجمل وأكثر دول أفريقيا أمانا
لكن كيف لدولة شهدت قبل 25 سنة
أكبر مصائب هذا القرن
أن تتجاوز كل ما حدث؟
نعتقد أن الكوارث التي مرت بها العراق
ستمنعنا من الإستمتاع بالحياة
لكن ما حدث برواندا يعطيني أملا كبيرا
فبما أنهم تجاوزوا ما حدث
فنحن أيضا نستطيع ذلك.
إذا استخدمنا الحلول الصحيحة.
وبالإضافة للإلهام والدروس التي استفدتها،
صرت أحمل مسؤولية على عاتقي أثناء سفري،
دائما ما يخبرني الناس
في أغلب المناطق التي زرتها
بأنني أول عراقي يصادفونه.
حتى أني قبل أسبوع زرت جزيرة سيشل
التي تقع بالمحيط الهندي،
ذهبت لشراء الأكل في أحد المطاعم،
فسألني صاحب المطعم عن أصولي
تفاجأ عندما أخبرته أني من العراق
وقال أنه لم يلتقي بعراقي من قبل
ترك كل شيء ودعاني للجلوس مع زوجته و ابنه،
استضافني وطلب مني أن أقيم ببيته
إذا زرت بلده مرة ثانية
وقد حصل معي نفس الشيء بكل الدول التي زرتها
حتى بفنزويلا التي تعتبر من الدول الفقيرة
استقبلتني إحدى العائلات ببيتها
مع أن أغلب العائلات هناك
لا تستطيع أن تحصل على وجبتين حتى
زرت طاجكستان أيضا وشهدت حدثا مهما
مع العائلة التي استضافتني
فقد اشتروا سيارة لأول مرة
بعدما اذخروا لسنوات لتوفير مبلغها،
وبما أنني عراقي فقد قمت بمباركة
السيارة بطريقتي.
(تصفيق)
فصرت أتجنب الفنادق
وأقيم عند الناس المحليين
أعرفهم على العراق وأشاركهم قصتي
التي دفعتني للسفر والتعرف عليهم،
و إدخال الجواز العراقي لكل هذه الدول
صار جزءا من رسالتي بالحياة
لكن لماذا يعتبر أسوء جواز سفر بالعالم
كل هذه الدول تضع قيود وتصعب الدخول إليها
لأنهم يخافون من العراقي.
وأنا أتحدى نظام الحدود والجوازات
التي وضعت لتصعب علينا السفر.
وأقول للناس عند زيارتي لأي دولة
أنا العراقي الذي تخافونه
واليوم أنا سأزور بلدكم وأدخل بيوتكم
سأتعرف عليكم وأقيم أوراش لطلابكم
وتجمعات لتلهم لشبابكم
وسأرحل بعد أن أترك أثرا إيجابيا.
(تصفيق)
(هتاف الجمهور)
الشيء المميز في قصتي أنه لا يوجد شيء مميز
أنا إنسان عادي،
و بداياتي الصعبة التي شاركتها معكم
أتشاركها مع أغلب الناس هنا
و مع الذين يشاهدون هذا الفيديو
كلنا عانينا و واجهنا صعوبات
وأنا لا أمتلك موهبة
بل أمتلك السوبر باور التي يمتلكها أي عراقي
عندما كنت صغيرا كان أهلي يقولون
أن شعار شعبنا هو تبا للمستحيل
ولم أفهم معنى هذه العبارة
إلى أن كبرت و حققت العديد من الإنجازات
التي أعتقدت انها مستحيلة
ولا زالت تبدو مستحيلة للعديد من الناس
لكني استطعت تحقيقها
مهلا،إذا كنا شعبا خرافيا ولدينا قوة خارقة،
فلماذا لدينا مشاكل؟
هل نتظاهر بانها غير موجودة؟
لنكن واقعيين، لدينا مشاكل معقدة
مرتبطة بأمور سياسية واقتصادية
لكن لدي فكرتين تبنيتهما
الأولى هي الأمل
الناس هنا قد فقدوا الأمل والإيمان
بأنفسهم وبقدراتهم
وأنا أتفهم هذا الأمر
لأنني كنت أظن في بداياتي أنني ملعون
ولن أستطيع عيش حياة سعيدة
بسبب تواجدي في العراق
والقوة الخارقة التي أتحدث عنها لن تعمل
إلا اذا فعلناها وآمنا بها و استخدمناها
و الثانية هي الدعم والمساعدات
التي يقدمها الآخرون.
وسأكون كاذبا إن قلت أني حققت كل هذا بمفردي
فقد دعمني أناس كثيرون بطرق غير متوقعة،
فأحيانا أتلقى من شخص 100 الى 200 دولار
لأجري امتحان الحصول على منحة
أنا ممتن لهؤلاء الناس
ودائما ما أفكر كيف سأرد جميلهم
مع أنني أعلم جيدا أنني لا أستطيع،
كل ما يمكنني فعله هو تمريره
هذه فكرة باي إت فوروارد
أو مرر الخير أو ادفع الخير إلى الأمام
بدل رده للشخص الذي بدأه.
لهذا قمت بمبادرات لدعم الشباب
والناس هنا بالعراق لديهم هذه السوبر باور
وكل ما يحتاجونه
هو دفعة صغيرة كالتي احتجتها.
وأكثر شيء أفادني في بداياتي
هو السفر والمنح الدراسية
لذلك أعمل على برامج تتضمن تدريبات
لها علاقة بالسفر والتدريب خارج البلد
وتعرفت من خلالها على شباب وبنات رائعين
كل واحد منهم له قصته
مع السوبر الباور التي أتحدث عنها،
وحققوا إنجازات رائعة خلال فترة قصيرة .
ومعتز واحد من هؤلاء الشباب،
هو من الموصل
و يقول أنا كنت ألعن وأكره وجودي
في هذه البقعة الجغرافية
هذا كلامه هو ولست أنا من كتبته
و بعد سفري خارج العراق،
اكتشفت الأشياء التي استفدت منها
خلال نشأتي في هذا البلد
وقد ترون نفسكم في هذه القصة .
و العمل الذي نقوم به لحد الآن
لا تدعمنا فيه الحكومة أو أي منظمة.
بل هو من تمويلنا الشخصي.
لكن هذا لا يكفي إذ يتواجد 8 مليون عراقي
تتراوح  أعمارهم بين الخمس عشرة
و الأربع وعشرين سنة
و هو نفس العمر الذي بدأت فيه مساري
وحصلت فيه على الدعم الذي كنت أحتاجه.
و يجب على كل فرد أن يفكر كيف يقدم الدعم
لهذه الفئة من الشباب.
لذلك اليوم من خلال هذه المنصة
أريد إطلاق مبادرة جديدة
واسمها سوبر إيراكيز فاند
و ستكون ببساطة صندوقا لتوفير الدعم للشباب
الذين يمتلكون هذه السوبر باور
و يريدون تفعيلها
و كل ما يحتاجونه هو قليل من الدعم المادي
أو المعنوي كالذي احتجناه بمراحل حياتنا
و سأكون أول شخص يتبرع لهذا الصندوق
بجزء من راتبي كل شهر
(تصفيق)
(هتاف الجمهور)
وإذا أردتم الإستفادة منه أو دعمه
ستجدون تفاصيل أكثر هنا
وأريد أن أضيف شيئا
مع أنني تجاوزت الوقت المحدد
وهو أن الحظ دائما يلعب دورا في كل نجاحاتنا
ودائما ما أتساءل كيف يزيد الشخص من حظوظه
ولازلت أبحث عن إجابة لهذا السؤال
لكن أكثر شيء يلهمني
هو هذه المقولة التي تقول:
فورشن فيفرز ذا بولد
معناها بالعربية الحظ سيحالف الجريء
أو الحظ يفضل الجريء
ودائما ما تجد هذه المقولة معلقة
بكل جدران شركة فيسبوك
و حسب تجربتي فإن هذا صحيح
كلما كنت جريئا ومغامرا ومجازفا
في اتخاذ قراراتي و خياراتي
كلما ازدادت حظوظي.
لذلك أريدكم  أن تفكروا بهذا اليوم
إذا أردت أن تكون أول عراقي يسير على القمر
او إذا كنت تريدين الحصول
على ميدالية ذهبية في الألعاب الأولمبية
مهما كانت طموحاتكم كبيرة أو صغيرة .
سيكون للحظ دور في تحقيق أهدافكم
لكن لنصبح محظوظين يجب أن نكون جريئين.
شكرا.
(تصفيق)
(هتاف الجمهور)